adult film actress stormy Daniels says
fear kept her from talking about an
alleged affair with President Trump she
told her complete story last night on 60
minutes it's already under attack by the
lawyer for Michael Cohen the president's
personal attorney stormy Daniel says she
signed a nondisclosure agreement because
she was worried about her and her
family's safety she claims that Michael
Cohen threatened her with financial ruin
to keep quiet the interview presents
possible legal challenges for Cohen and
mr. Trump major Garrett is at the White
House which has said nothing about the
60 minutes story major good morning good
morning Daniel's discussed in some
detail this alleged affair with
President Trump it's one she had
previously denied by the way she also
made mention of an alleged threat
against her and her daughter now on the
eve of the 60 minutes broadcast that
went into all of this the President had
dinner with his lawyer Michael Cohen the
two of them of course are at the center
of this ongoing legal and political
drama I was in a parking lot going to a
fitness class with my infant daughter
and a guy walked up on me and said to me
leave Trump alone forget the story and
then he leaned around and looked at my
daughter and said that's a beautiful
little girl would be a shame if
something happened to her mom and then
he was gone
in an interview with 60 minutes stormy
Daniels says she was first threatened to
stay silent in 2011 you took it as a
direct threat absolutely I was rattled I
remember going into the workout class
and my hands are shaking so much I was
afraid I was gonna drop her did you go
to the police no why because I was
scared
Daniel says she doesn't know who
threatened her her lawyer Michael
avenatti says a new lawsuit filed by
Cohen is meant to intimidate his client
there's no question you threatened
someone with a 20 million dollar lawsuit
it's a thuggish tactic it's no different
than what happened in the parking lot in
Las Vegas Michael Cohen has denied ever
threatening Daniel's his lawyer fired
back overnight at avenatti with a cease
and desist letter calling allegations
she was threatened baseless mr. Cohen
had absolutely nothing whatsoever to do
with any such person or incident and
does not even believe that any such
person exists was it hush money to stay
yes the story was coming out again I was
concerned for my family and their safety
after signing a nondisclosure agreement
Daniel said she lied in statements where
she denied having an affair with mr.
Trump if it was untruthful
why did you sign it because they made it
sound like I had no choice yeah I mean
no one was putting a gun to your head
not physical violence now you thought
that there would be some sort of legal
repercussions if you didn't sign that as
a matter of fact the exact sentence used
was they can make your life hell in many
different ways they being I'm not
exactly sure who they were I believe it
to be Michael Cohen no comment from the
White House about all this an attorney
for mr. Trump referred 60 minutes to a
January signed a statement of denial
from Daniels which read in part my
involvement with Donald Trump was
limited to a few public appearances and
nothing more Noora all right major thank
you